[Music]
[Music]
this is Sophie ecology right I can't
take the call right now but I promise I
will call you back
have a great day I just need to take a
little break you're gonna have to tell
them that I'm not coming back
yeah I know I've been trying to get a
hold it for myself
special delivery
[Music]
how did you know I was here I read Seuss
story and the paper about this famous
Hollywood actress who disappeared I'm
working on a film version of King Lear
you didn't Cordelia
and we could talk
[Music]
dad what is all this crap oh I'm sorry
sweetheart
I just get directed okay so I stand
there like then I get told where to go
and that's what I do you know we have to
do is memorize the lines and exit out I
want you to be an artist where the hell
have you been all these years dad you
haven't changed one bit
[Music]
I've always loved you
you have the talent don't be ridiculous
Shakespeare's greatest play Romeo and
Juliet was his best play dad we weren't
arguing talk about that another time
[Music]